Mọi đồng bá lý nước của người mình bày thống mình mô đã thông qua nghị quyết về các gia gió Mỹ sản thảo,
mà đường chưa việc chiến khai lực tượng của tế và thành là khội đồng phá bình,
giới sự sân sách của tổng thống Mi đường nên trăm.
Cái bình này lập tất vấp phải các phản nân khăn nhau từ khu vực và tục đồng của tế.
Đại giữa an Jerry khần định, mọi sang kiến hoa bình,
phải đặt công li chúng người palestine ở biển chi chúng tâm,
nhến mạnh như cầu thành lập nhẹn nước palestine đặc lập.
Firmý e-mô tảng hệ quét là bất đi mang tính lịch sử,
cho rằng cơ trì mới giúp cảnh thiết an ninh quét sửa,
và tạo đu kiện để gà ra phục hồi.
Đồng thời chào chung người palestine quyền tự quét,
tuy nhiên ngà và Trung Quốc bỏ phía chắn,
cho rằng văn kiện còn thiếu nhiều chi tế quan chạm,
linh quan tự cấu và nhự vụ của lực lượng của tế.
Isorem Hàn Ngây về của loại bỏ hà mắt khỏi vai trò điều hành tại gà ra,
nhưng phản đối nội dung linh quan tự lộ trình nhả nước palestine.
Ngược lại, chính quyền palestine ủng hộ nghị quét,
trong khi hà mắt bỏ,
bà cho rằng cơ trì khu tế của thế làm gia tăng người cơ đối đầu,
nhưng phản đứng nè chú thấy còn tổn tại sự phần ngoài Trung Quốc định hướng tổn lai của giải kia ra.